losing a co-founder and losing our
biggest client on the same day and then
randomly raising like another $500,000
all in the same day was the most erratic
rollercoaster of a day it's a day that
if you're planning on being an
entrepreneur if you could live that one
day that's a good test for your
emotional ability to deal with those
those highs and lows hi my name is James
Heller I'm the CEO rapa Phi and I'm 29
years old we pay people to advertise on
their car I actually needed this service
I was marketing an event in San Diego
and I really wanted to put wrapped
vehicles in the tech sector of San Diego
I thought it'd be a great way to raise
awareness for the event and I learned
really quickly that there wasn't a
company that did this
[Music]
it was so obvious to me that I couldn't
believe that nobody has done it yet
there are people that have tried to do
it and haven't been able to reach the
scale that we've reached so far in the
short you know less than two years we've
been live taking a small very simple
concept building technology to support
it and then actually bringing it to
market and having it having it actually
consumed and embraced that is that's
beautiful that's what I love I love
waking up and going to work to do
everyday
[Music]
I've conned my parents into building an
eBay account that I could use to sell
crap in the garage and basically
repurpose items that I've had or like
toys or things that I needed to
regenerate money because my parents
didn't give me an allowance there's so
much that learned from that experience
that carried on into my early commerce
career and then that evolved into where
I became a b2b digital marketer and then
that you know that really sparked my
charisma and enthusiasm for for the ad
industry and building an ad platform as
I lived in so many different ad
platforms on a day to day basis I really
wanted to build one that hasn't really
seen the light of day at the scale I
wanted to see
[Music]
I want wrap up I to not just be a brand
that's a go-to for advertising on
consumer vehicles but I want people to
say they want to get their car wrap of
five I want that to be that to be the
standout not only do I want to own this
category nationwide by expect on this
category on a global scale and that's
what we're driving for
[Music]